everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm here
to bring you exciting review for
Telltale's long-awaited sequel to their
season 1 of The Walking Dead this one's
a season 2 episode one's called all that
remains and for poor Clementine
unfortunately there's not much left for
her this has been one of my favorite
video game new video game series it's
come out recently I know Dennis not have
been kind of harsh on our Walking Dead
reviews the season we let we both enjoy
the mid-season finale but unfortunately
the season as a whole hasn't been that
great in my opinion but I told you guys
that I am still passionate about the
walking dead franchise as a whole I
still read the comics i love the comics
but this is where my passion is right
now with the walking dead the telltale
Game doing such a good job for those of
you who are interested more in telltale
what they got going on right now they
recently announced it going to a game of
thrones series as well as Borderlands
and hopefully they'll continue to do
after season two wraps up locally we'll
do a season three so we're not going to
spoil too much for what happened in
season one let's just say that right now
Clementine is alone I think of all the
characters and the whole Walking Dead
universe of comics video games the TV
series Clementine is probably my
favorite character here we see her a
little bit more grown up you know again
the throes of you didn't play season one
Clementine was partnered with a man
named Lee an escaped convict who's you
know good guy just got up you know mixed
up in the wrong you know things some bad
things happen for the guy you know it
just happens is convicted of murder and
because of the zombie apocalypse you
know meets Clementine you know we also
get to see some some other walking dead
characters as well you might be familiar
with if you decide to play season one
which I highly recommend but season two
Clementine at least as we see her now is
alone in the woods you know tough girl
it's about I don't know a year and a
half later so she's a little bit older
she's growing up probably I'm guessing I
don't know 10 11 maybe by now and she
says she's awesome she's like probably
my favorite female characters and
entertainment right now I think she's so
well done in this game I mean the things
that she has to endure there's a couple
scenes again no spoilers but like she
has to
do some things and you'll win so if you
haven't gotten there yet and you do
you'll see it you'll whence I mean
there's some scenes that she has because
this little poor little girl 10 11 year
old girl has to you know just fight to
survive it's not like you see with Rick
and Carl in their relationship how you
know Rick looks after Carly Carl's tough
you know in the TV series but I mean
Clementine is really on her own and this
girl i mean i don't know maybe car would
be more interesting character in the TV
series if they put him on his own i know
that would be kind of it's not going to
happen in the TV series because the main
characters are too important but in a
video game you have a lot more room for
expression a lot more room for
creativity and you see it in Telltale's
Game I mean even the fighting mechanics
so the action moves i should say have
changed but for those of you familiar
with tell tales games they have a wolf
among us game that's out right now
that's based off of Vertigo's comic book
series fables which is a great series
also a great game and the action
mechanics or a little improved chairman
you are I mean I'm playing on PC so I'm
clicking with my mouse but you you know
use the arrow or you know your your
stick to move over is a little bit more
movement involves a lot smoother the
graphics are better they beefed up their
engine everything this game is just a
step above what season one was and of
course we only get the first episode
this month hopefully we'll get episode
too soon there's really no telling when
you know telltale is going to release
that but if this is any indication this
could be a better season in season one I
mean again I'm trying to avoid spoilers
here but you get to play as Clementine
she's a great character play season one
if you haven't already check it out this
is definitely one of the better games I
can't do game of the year anything with
this because it's only episode 1 there's
still more episodes to come but it's
definitely worth it's only about two
hours worth the gameplay but again it's
just it's just great again one of my
favorite characters so you know as
always you know come share your thoughts
with me talk to me about what you think
about Clementine have you tried this
game out have you had a chance to ever
play one of the telltale games have you
tried wolf among us and they did a
Jurassic Park game I think I believe as
well let me know what your thoughts are
you know how do you compare to the comic
book series to the TV show what are your
thoughts this is my favorite thing going
on with the walking dead right now is
tell tales game I'm sorry like the TV
series is it's okay sometimes I'm not as
into it this is where my passion lies
right now is with this video game I
still like the comics but I think this
is the
so as always you know you can come find
this chat with us on think hero.com you
can also check us out on this YouTube
page here think here or pro you know
sherry tosses us you know what you think
you can also find Dennis Michael myself
we're all on twitter at think hero
personally i'm at griffin de we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think here of fans and please be
sure to LIKE subscribe spread the word
share what you're feeling about The
Walking Dead universe in general what do
you think we think about the spin-off
series coming out with you about the
video game the television series
everything going on right now at the
walking dead we want to hear your
thoughts I wanna know what you think if
you've had a chance to play this with
just great game